hey this is preshtalwalka reminding you
to mind your decisions
start with the square
pick a point in the interior
the distance to the upper left corner is
the square root of 17 to the lower left
corner is 2 and to the lower right
corner is 5.
solve for the area of the square
this problem is adapted from a southeast
asian mathematical olympia test where
students had about 5 minutes per
question
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started by color coding the
distances to each corner
this problem can be solved with an
interesting technique we'll rotate the
entire diagram from the lower left
corner 90 degrees
now we'll consider the angles in this
diagram
consider this purple angle
once it's rotated it'll end up right
here
since the corner of a square is a right
angle when we rotate this diagram this
will also become a right angle
consequently these two yellow lines are
the legs of an isosceles right triangle
these angles will be equal to 45 degrees
and its hypotenuse will be 2 times the
square root of 2.
now focus on this triangle
notice
that the square of 2 times the square
root of 2 plus the square of the square
root of 17 is exactly equal to 5 squared
this is because 8 plus 17 is equal to 25
that means this is a right angle
triangle and this is a right angle
now let's erase all the parts on the
left
let's focus just on the right
right here we have an angle that's 45
degrees plus 90 degrees and that's equal
to 135 degrees
let's write x for the side of the square
by alkashi's law of cosines x squared is
equal to the square root of 17 squared
plus 2 squared minus 2 times the square
root of 17 times 2 times the cosine of
135 degrees
we'll simplify each term and we can
gradually solve for x squared
17 plus 4 is equal to 21
and this entire thing will be
subtracting a negative and it ends up
being plus 2 times the square root of
34.
so x squared is equal to 21 plus 2 times
the square root of 34.
now recall we want the area of the
square and the area of the square is
exactly its side length squared which is
equal to x squared
and we've already solved for that so
that's our answer the area of the square
is 21 plus 2 times the square root of
34.
incredible
thanks for watching and for making my
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]